hola a todos hoy vamos a aprender a
acompañar y monitorear el progreso de
nuestros estudiantes usando cada cable
ahora estamos en la página principal de
los maestros la que tengo todas las
clases que he creado como profesora no
voy a entrar a una de las clases
en la que mis estudiantes ya han podido
hacer las tareas que les dije voy a
hacer clic en la pestaña donde dice
tareas
y aquí la primera opción que me da es
ver el avance por tareas como ven aquí
aparecen los nombres de todas las tareas
que dejado ya sean vídeos ejercicios
artículos
y veo la fecha y hora límite en la que
las dejé si bien en la segunda columna
también cuántas personas han completado
de todos mis estudiantes por ejemplo el
primer vídeo no lo ha visto todavía
ninguno de los estudiantes el segundo
vídeo ya lo he visto uno de ellos en el
ejercicio o fracciones equivalentes
modelos de fracciones ya lo han hecho 23
de mis estudiantes de los 35 que tengo
en la clase y como ven cuando hay
ejercicios que ya se han cumplido se
habilita esta pestaña de ver reporte
vamos a ver qué es lo que nos muestra
clic ahí nos va a aparecer
un reporte en el que vemos todos los
ejercicios que le dejamos a nuestros
estudiantes
en la parte izquierda el primer
ejercicio que aparece es el ejercicio 11
porque es el ejercicio que tiene más
errores como ven 5 alumnos tuvieron
errores en este ejercicio y 5 alumnos lo
hicieron bien aquí en la parte derecha
podemos ver quiénes fueron los
estudiantes que lo hicieron
correctamente y quienes no los primeros
5 ven que tienen aquí un mapa en que lo
hicieron incorrectamente pero también
podemos ver cuántos intentos les tomó
llegar a ese resultado no la primera
estudiante margarita lo intentó siete
veces y así podemos ver que no pudo
llegar a cumplir correctamente ese
ejercicio eso quiere decir que como
maestros podemos acercarnos a ese
estudiante y explicarle mejor este
ejercicio principalmente que es el que
estamos viendo aquí a la izquierda
sin embargo tenemos otros alumnos que si
lo hicieron correctamente y en la
primera oportunidad que lo intentaron
nosotros podemos mostrar esto a todos
los estudiantes o podemos hacerlo
independientemente cada uno en el
momento de planificación o reflexión
sobre la clase si lo queremos mostrar la
clase tenemos aquí el ejercicio aquí en
el lado izquierdo donde dice no mueve el
punto para graficar dos puntos en la
recta numérica podemos mostrarles estos
estudiantes y hacerlo con ellos en la
clase también podemos usar khan academy
como si fuera una pizarra interactiva
haciéndole clic aquí en la pestaña donde
dice dibujar y aquí la plataforma te
permite hacer justamente las líneas y
poder explicar nuevamente el ejercicio
asimismo si quisiera
hacerle clic a donde dice pistas podemos
ver una explicación de este ejercicio
para que el profesor lo comparta los
estudiantes o el mismo también lo pueda
revisar para tenerlo un poco más claro
antes de trabajarlo con todos
así podemos ver cada uno de los
ejercicios los estudiantes han ido
haciendo por ejemplo el ejercicio 5 si
vemos aquí el lado izquierdo
vemos que tres alumnos tuvieron
dificultades y así sucesivamente no
podemos ir viendo en las respuestas
quiénes fueron de ellos los que tuvieron
problemas quienes respondieron
correctamente y así iremos viendo en
cada uno de ellos para volver a la
pestaña de tareas hacemos clic en la
izquierda
y volvemos a la página principal donde
veíamos todas las tareas que hemos
dejado con el avance
además podemos ver cómo es el progreso
de cada uno de los estudiantes haciendo
clic a la pestaña donde dice por alumno
si le hacemos clic aquí
vamos a ver la lista de todos los
estudiantes junto con todas las tareas
que les hemos dejado y una especie de
semáforo no con el mayor puntaje logrado
por ejemplo vamos a ver a esta primera
estudiante de adelaida ella sólo ha
cumplido con dos de estas tareas la
primera fue un artículo que ya lo vio
por eso sale un check
y la segunda que son ejercicios aunque
tienen este este lápiz
tuvo el 100% no se llegó al 100%
contestó todo correctamente
tenemos otros estudiantes por ejemplo
como elena romero que cumplió 4 las
tareas pero en tres de ellas está en el
color amarillo que quiere decir que
todavía puede mejorar
y quienes aparecen en el color rojo es
quienes todavía tienen mayores
dificultades y así podemos ver el
proceso de toda nuestra clase de una
forma muy sencilla
y el maestro pueda decidir justamente
qué hacer con esta información podría
por ejemplo juntar a quienes tienen
mayores problemas con algunos ejercicios
con o con quienes lo resolvieron
correctamente o podría dejarles más
tareas del mismo tema a algunos
estudiantes y a los que ya están más
avanzados seguir con el siguiente tema
de dificultad además lo que permite
hacer esta plataforma es hacer reportes
individualizados por ejemplo si yo
quisiera ver el reporte de joel guerra
aquí le hago clic a su nombre
y me lleva a una página en la que veo
todas las tareas que le dejé yo en el
estado en el que están estas tareas
cuántos intentos tuvo y cuál fue la
mejor puntuación a la que llevo este
tipo de reportes son reportes muy
interesantes cuando se quieren por
ejemplo compartir con los padres de
familia o cuando se llama a cada uno
estudiantes para que vean su progreso
personalizado volvemos a la página de
tareas
y aquí aparecen un grupo de tareas pero
si yo lo he dejado más tareas a mis
estudiantes le tengo que hacer clic
donde dice siguiente aquí en la derecha
y me aparecerán más tareas que les ha
ido dejando a mis estudiantes
por ejemplo vemos aquí un gran grupo de
estudiantes que no ha cumplido esas
tareas
el maestro podrá preguntarles qué es lo
que pasó sean ha tenido alguna
dificultad o porque no las han cumplido
esta pestaña de tareas es muy
interesante para los profesores
honestidad porque pueden ver el progreso
de sus estudiantes
por alumno lo cual ayuda a atender mejor
la diversidad de su clase otra forma muy
interesante de ver es a los estudiantes
es con la pestaña que dice actividad y
le hacemos clic aquí
donde dice actividad
vamos a ponerlo no la actividad los
últimos siete días sino de todo el
tiempo entonces son tareas que ya se
dejaron hace bastantes semanas y aquí
vemos a toda la lista de la clase
nuevamente con unas barras que lo que
muestran es el tiempo que el estudiante
estuvo activo en la plataforma
y qué quiere decir que estuvo activo no
quiere decir que abrió la plataforma y
le dejó abierta sino que estuvo
activamente viendo algún vídeo o
tratando de resolver ejercicios esto le
permite al maestro ver realmente cuánto
tiempo activo tiene el estudiante en la
plataforma por ejemplo acá podrá ver el
maestro que tiene un alumno que nunca ha
ingresado o tiene por otro lado otra
alumna juliana pérez que tiene el mayor
tiempo de uso no por ejemplo si lo vemos
aquí ponemos el cursor sobre estas
barras cada barra representa un momento
diferente en la que la estudiante se
conectó a la plataforma y estuvo
activamente no los colores que ven es
por la hora en la que la estudiante
estuvo en la plataforma el color gris
claro es que se hizo durante las horas
de clase
que según khan academy lo tiene marcado
hasta las 3 de la tarde si fuera después
de las 3 de la tarde se marcará con el
color gris oscuro que fuera de las horas
de la escuela esto es importante porque
el maestro puede usar khan academy
durante la hora escolar pero también lo
puede dejar como tareas la idea es que
el estudiante siga aprendiendo desde
cualquier lugar y el maestro pueda
seguir monitoreando el progreso de los
estudiantes desde cualquier lugar
también entonces por ejemplo este
estudiante julián a
acá nos dice que el día
12 109 18 estuvo en la plataforma por 15
minutos a las 5 de la tarde de 50 7 a 5
23 y hizo no las habilidades de
fracciones equivalentes y modelos de
fracciones en otro momento no en otro
día estuvo 21 minutos y vio tres vídeos
e hizo unos unos ejercicios durante la
clase estuvo en otro momento 29 minutos
y en otro otro día estuvo 34 y así el
maestro puede ir viendo cada uno de los
casos y acercándose los estudiantes de
preguntarles a quienes tienen menos
tiempo qué es lo que pasa no tal vez
tienen problemas de conectividad con
nuestros equipos y a quienes sí los
vienen usando también felicitarlos y
justamente ver si el tema de la cantidad
de tiempo de uso tiene relación con lo
que vimos en la pestaña de las tareas
y el mayor puntaje logrado algo
importante que siempre resaltamos a los
maestros que les sugerimos es que
reconozcan y de una forma
valor en premier él
el uso de la plataforma por partes
estudiantes porque quiere decir que
tienen muchas ganas de seguir
aprendiendo más allá de que tal vez no
lleguen al mejor resultado si lo
intentan muchas veces van a poder seguir
siendo perseverantes y lograrán obtener
el aprendizaje esperado entonces estos
paneles de control son muy importantes
para los maestros para aquellos pueden
hacer un seguimiento muy de cerca a qué
es lo que pasa en su clase y puedan
atender de la mejor forma el ritmo con
el que cada uno esos estudiantes
aprenden para poder acompañarlo en su
aprendizaje en su aprendizaje